I just learned something the other day
it was real bad news and it really
[ __ ] pissed me off and I think I want
to voice it right now but form is yours
uh basically I'm not talking about the
whole country I'm talking about one
theater in particular are you sound
nervous about this wow that's a big
[ __ ] deal alright alright go ahead
alright so uh we were going to play at
the center I'm a dome right on the 25th
we were going to open there and play
there exclusively for two weeks and Star
Wars was going to play the two weeks
before us and I always I mean listen I
grew up in Los Angeles oh I think of the
Cinerama Dome as a real big deal and
imagine seeing it at the Cinerama Dome
means something to you exactly right
Disney who owns Star Wars yes decided
well you know what maybe we want to play
throughout the entire holiday season
and not you know so we're going to go to
the ceramic dome and say that they can't
honor their contract right with us to
show the hateful a and the arc like
people that own the Cinerama Dome said
no no no you can't do that we have a
deal with the hateful eight people and
and showing it in seventy that's what we
do we have the 70 million projectors
they don't have to move them in that's
the thing we even start off with the
Cinerama logo right at the beginning as
of yesterday Disney came to the ArcLight
people and said no wow you are going to
play Star Wars in the Cinerama Dome for
the entire holiday season and if you
don't if you honor your deal with the
hateful eight we will not allow you to
have Star Wars the biggest movie in the
world we will not allow you to show it
at any of your arc like movies so in
your mind that's petty because they've
got a big blockbuster on their hands
biggest movie in the world we're talking
about one effing theater here they are
going out of their way to [ __ ] me
Quentin all fairness I must say there's
nobody from Disney here to refute that
or to say that's as far as I'm concerned
and left all the entertainment reporters
call up Disney as of now and ask for
their comments about their extortionist
practices listen Bob took a bob iger
I don't give a [ __ ] about this theater
questions are weird oh sorry Quentin dip
the [ __ ] kid they got the ik with
this stupid 70 millimeter got all that
[ __ ] that he cares about you just wants
to show his goddamn movie there you got
your sitting on top of the world you got
Star Wars well what do you need this do
me a favor Bobby for me and you know
we've had many private conversations I
[ __ ] partied with this guy over Jimmy
Kimmel's Oh Bobby it would be gracious
be a gracious man I want Quentin to show
this new movie he's worked his ass off
he wants the equipment hatefully would
you do it for me
alright Christmas it's Christmas
Christ's sake
you